hey guys
we're having some technical problems
over here at
world science festival world science u
but
i'm hoping that i'm streaming right now
i could be talking
to myself here in upstate new york but
let me know
in the chat if we're actually live that
would be uh
useful to hear and obviously i'd love to
know where you guys are connecting from
as we
carry on with the live session you may
note that there's been a
a kind of a long break between
the last session and today
and you know a lot a lot has gone in the
world a lot has gone on for me
personally i think some of you know that
you know my mom who
came up in these sessions now and then
and when we were first doing them she
passed away on
on june 6th so from the virus
so we've been dealing with that and that
was at least partly why we stopped these
sessions for a while but i'm happy to
start them up again if you guys are
interested to continue the conversations
that
that we were having the other thing that
motivated today's live session
is a relaunch of world
science u this is the educational
platform of world science festival it's
completely free and really cool you
should go check it out
and we launched it a long time ago with
a handful
of classes and courses and the relaunch
if you go check it out you know there's
about 40 or so
faculty from around the world many of
the most prominent scientists
in the world nobel laureates
people like barry barish who discover
gravitational waves people like alan
guth who discovered the inflationary
theory people who have
already established themselves as the
next generation of leading scientists
are part of this as well so definitely
worth checking out world
science u for these what we call master
class
experiences i will be interviewing
as part of your daily equation a kind of
combination of your daily equation and
world science we'll be doing some live
conversations with some of these great
thinkers
so you're used to these sessions where i
just sort of sit here
for some period of time and just talk
and talk answer your questions and so
forth we'll kind of break it up a little
bit
where you guys can ask questions not
just of me but
of some of these of these great figures
that that you may know of that you may
have read about
their works you may be deeply influenced
by the theories and discoveries that
they have
provided to us now my own
particular course on world science use
some of you may have already taken it
focused on special relativity i still
intend
to have courses on quantum mechanics and
general relativity
and now that that site is up and
functional i'm more motivated to
consider doing that so i'm happy to uh
to do that going forward
but what i'd like to do today is in some
sense
interview myself so i'm going to kind of
spend the first
hour focusing both on your questions but
also on those that are more
tightly related to the special theory
of relativity is that is what my world
science u
current course is all about so i think
i'm going to jump
in right now on some of those questions
and some of them i've collected from
various sources so i'm always excited to
answer
your live questions like m says is this
john
cusack uh no no it's just me but that
just establishes of course that this
really is live
nothing better than answering
an impromptu question to to establish
that but i'm going to focus
for a little bit on questions that focus
on the special theory
of relativity and one that i'm asked all
the time
is what's the best way what's the
simplest way what's the most intuitive
way
to grasp the counter-intuitive notion
that time slows down
when you are watching a clock in motion
so if you're watching a clock in motion
that clock will take off time ever more
slowly
and the best answer to that is the
oldest answer to that there is no
newfangled
approach that really blows out of the
water
any of the other attempts to explain
this
powerful idea of
time and its rate of elapsing depending
upon
your state of motion than the light
clock
and the light clock is this very simple
but
powerful idea where you know when you
think about
clocks right i mean there are many many
ways of
of thinking about clocks they're
basically devices
that allow us to
measure the duration between one event
and another we do that by having a
cyclical process
so if the clock is an ordinary
old-fashioned clock the cyclical process
is a hand that just sweeps around the
face of the dial
that's one kind of cyclical process
there are many such processes
right a quartz crystal it vibrates in a
particular cyclical manner you count the
number of vibrations to determine
how much time is elapsed but a light
clock what is it
it's a device that has two mirrors
with a ball of light that bounces up and
down
between the mirrors and to calculate the
amount of time that's gone by
you simply kept the number of tick tocks
of the bouncing photon between
those mirrors and let me just give you a
little visual
of that if i can bring this up on a
screen here yeah so
you know if you see this clock and you
see you got the two mirrors
that are facing each other and the ball
of light is bouncing
up and down between them and each of
those tick
tock tick tocks that
is a way of counting
the duration of measuring the amount of
time
that has elapsed now once you take
into mind into your brain
fully the idea that that clock
that you're seeing it's truly measuring
time
it's an unfamiliar clock you don't see
people walking around on planet earth
with a wristwatch
that's a little box that has a photon
bouncing up and down between two
parallel mirrors but once you take
that notion of time as really being time
right if you're measuring how much time
is a lot you simply count the tick tocks
in that photon
then there's an incredibly simple
way of concluding that when a clock is
in motion
time slows down and to do that you
simply show
two of these clocks and you say put one
oops i'm i'm blocking that thing over
there i think so you put one
on the other side of the laboratory let
me get out of the way here and look at
the
photon in the moving clock it has to
travel
a longer trajectory a diagonal up and a
diagonal down
trajectory light always travels at the
same speed
so if the photon in the moving clock let
me get out of the way here and play it
again
if the photon in the moving clock is
traveling along
a longer trajectory diagonal up diagonal
down is much longer than the straight up
and down of the stationary clock then
look
it will go tick tock
more slowly
than it would in the stationary
clock and that example let me get out of
the way here so you can see it
that example right there is a beautiful
illustration
of how time slows down
on a moving clock constancy of the speed
of light
and the longer duration of the
tick tocks in the moving clock
is to my mind the most
powerful means of
embracing viscerally this notion
that time slows down on a moving clock
and there you see the
the essential new idea of special
relativity that was
einstein's insight that the speed of
light is constant
whether you're looking at the ball of
light in the stationary clock or on the
moving clock the speed
at which light travels is the same
671 million miles per hour or whatever
units you like to use 300 million meters
per second
and so if the light has to travel on
a longer trajectory it's going to
tick-tock less
frequently time will slow down
on a moving clock so if you have
questions on that i consider this to be
you should ask him now i consider this
to be
among the greatest achievements of the
human mind
that little illustration of the bouncing
ball of light establishing
that time slows down on a moving clock
is
one of the deepest insights of the human
mind so if you have questions on that
i'd love to entertain them
but that's the the basic idea
now others ask as i see some of you are
asking
well okay that's the effect on time
is there an effect on space and there is
an effect on space i don't know how easy
it will be
for me to show you that but i can show
you the basic
the basic idea and in fact
let me just see if i can get this guy
over here so
yeah so this little illustration over
here
shows you that if you want the speed of
light to be constant and if you learn
that time is not constant
then space can't be constant either
because what is speed
speed is nothing but how far you go
divided by how long it takes you to get
there and if the speed of light is fixed
at 671 million miles per hour
and if time is something that
is malleable as we just saw time in
motion
slows down then space
has to also have a reaction to motion
because it has to react in just the
right way to cancel out
the slowing of time to keep the speed of
light namely the ratio of space per time
to keep that fixed so that's the basic
idea where we learn
immediately that
space has to also be effective but let
me show you now
what that effect looks like so here's a
taxi cab
traveling along i'm gonna go where
should i sit for these guys
yeah i guess this is a good location as
any of this sits let me show you this
again
this is a taxi cab that is speeding down
a street in manhattan and look at that
taxi cab
it's squeezed along the direction of
motion
this is what you'd actually see if
attacks if you could see things that are
moving near the speed of light and if a
new york city taxi cab could travel near
the speed of light
this is what you'd actually see space
is crushed squeezed lorentz contracted
along the direction of motion
so those are the big effects
of the special theory of
relativity and they're they're deep
right i mean
you know they're absolutely deep you
know and the reverse
i should also say is true we in this
little animation
are on the sidewalk looking at the
taxicab
as it is streaming by right
but you could also ask yourself what if
you're in the taxi cab
looking at the outer world from the
perspective
of an object that's moving near the
speed of light i think i can show you
that one
too i think this will show yeah so here
we are inside a taxicab here i am
driving along
near the speed of light facing the wrong
direction normally you face
forward right not to face like this but
look outside so the world it's
shrunken it's actually even curved in
along the direction of motion that's
because
when we see things we see them because
the light has to travel from the object
to our
eyeball and so light is traveling from
different locations
it will travel different distances
and therefore we'll reach our eyeball at
different moments and therefore we're
seeing a given object
at different moments in time because the
light had to leave earlier from a more
distant location to reach our eye
at the same moment that the light is
traveling from a nearer location so that
that's cool that's what
a city block would look like if you're
streaming along
near the speed of light so
you know it's kind of cool stuff and
it's unintuitive stuff
and that's how the world works according
to albert einstein's special theory
of relativity so let me take a couple
questions and i see one here from
aryan tewari if we move the light clock
why doesn't the speed of light relative
to us be
greater than the speed of light yeah
aryan you're asking
the deep and important question at the
heart of
fundamental physics you would think
ariane
and everybody else that if
you for instance turn on a flashlight
while you're running forward you would
think
that your forward motion would kick up
the speed of light
to be a little bit larger than what it
is
when you turn on the flashlight from a
stationary position i mean that's
why in the game of cricket why does
what's it called the dude who throws the
ball in a game of cricket the bowler
i don't know you guys i know some of you
are from india so please correct my
terminology
but you know in baseball the pitcher
doesn't run forward but in cricket
the bowler does run forward why does the
boulder run forward
because the bowler knows that the
bowler's motion forward
will be transmitted to the ball
that the bowler is throwing forward and
it will go
faster right you can make the ball go
faster by not throwing it from a
stationary position
rather you throw it or you bowl it if
that's the correct language from a
running forward position
it's so intuitive it's so basic it's how
the world works
in an everyday sensorial
experience but that
doesn't translate to light if you run
forward while turning on a flashlight
the speed of the light
is exactly the same as it would be if
you turn on the flashlight as at rest
your forward motion unlike the case of
cricket
does not add any additional speed
to that which is intrinsic to the light
itself now ariana asks why is that
answer i don't know i do not know why
the speed of light is constant
nobody really knows why the speed of
light is gone let me take the word
really out
nobody knows why the speed of light is
constant
we do know that experiments and
observation establish that the speed of
light is constant
and we do know that if you're albert
einstein you can use
that fact to deduce
other qualities of the world that are
completely unexpected like the slowing
of time
for a clock in motion like the squeezing
of space for an object
in motion but aryan could there be
another reality another universe which
the speed of light is not constant i
i sure i don't think there's any logical
necessity of the speed of light being
constant
and yet it is and all we
meager human beings do is extract the
consequences of this fact
of the speed of life being constant and
among those facts among those
consequences i should say are the ones
that i've shown you
the slowing of time and the squeezing
of space so so that's
as far as you know that's how it all
works
and it could have been different
but apparently it is not so coco coco
asks
if the time slows down for a moving
clock
shouldn't the rate at which the said
clock goes
decrease instead of increase as shown by
the lorenz transformation it's really
irritating for me
i'm trying to understand the question
coco coco let me just read it again if
time slows down for a moving clock
i'm good shouldn't the rate at which the
that clock
goes i guess moves decrease and say oh i
see what you're saying yeah good good
good
i understand completely so here's the
thing um
coco coco imagine that
instead of a clock in motion you're
watching me
in motion and i am say walking across
and you say time for me is slowing down
now what does that mean what that means
is if you look at me carefully
you will see me slow down you will see
me in slow motion
you will see my head turn slowly my
eyes will blink slowly everything about
me
will be in slow motion so that's the
sense
coco coco in which the said
clock will decrease
that's the sense in which the object in
motion
will experience time slowing down
my own speed let's say i'm on a
skateboard or i'm in a car
my speed won't slow down my speed is one
of the givens of the physical situation
our relative motion is what we are given
and we are saying
that you looking at me you are seeing my
bodily form in
aggregate moving at a certain speed near
the speed of light
that's a given but when you then look at
my
intrinsic motion within
that vehicle that may be traveling near
the speed of light
you will indeed see me going slower
you will indeed see time slowing down
for me and in fact if i look back at you
from my position in the car i will see
you in slow motion your eyes will be
blinking slowly your arms will be moving
slowly
so that's the sense in which
the moving object appears to be in slow
motion
its own intrinsic speed from being in
the vehicle
is part of the given information of the
physical situation that we're analyzing
i hope that coca-cola that doesn't do it
for you ask again
but that's the uh that's the key idea
orcas sorry again
you know me i'm awful on learning how to
pronounce names but
o-r-c-v-s if s-dichia asks
have you figured out why any of the
constants are what they are and of
course among those constants is the
constant speed of light
why do the constants have the values
that they do well
from one perspective
when it comes to the speed of light
there's nothing special about the number
300 million meters per second 186 000
miles
per second 671 million miles per hour
you see i'm doing this because you see
that the numbers
change depending on your units so it's
merely
you choose a unit for measuring distance
you choose a unit for measuring time the
second or the hour for distance it could
be
the meter or the kilometer or the mile
or the inch whatever you choose your
units and then the speed of light
is some particular number in those units
but that number is not special it
totally depends on the units that you
choose in fact if you choose your unit
to be for distance
to be the foot i know it's the archaic
angular system but whatever
and if you choose the duration of time
to be measured in nanoseconds
then the speed of light is very close to
one foot per nanosecond
one foot per nano so it's one speed of
light is one
in those units so there you see you can
make it any number that you want
the deep question though is if you look
at ratios
of these constants of nature ratios that
have no units
for instance the mass of the
electron divided by the mass of the up
quark
that's a number that's unit independent
whatever units you use for the mass of
the electron and whatever
units have used the same one for the
mass of the up quark
if you take the ratio of those two
masses
then the units drop out
and you're left with a pure number and
that pure number
cries out for explanation and that
orcas is really the question that you're
asking
and no we've not made any progress on
understanding those dimensionless
those unitless ratios we don't know why
the electron mass to the various quark
masses have the values
that they do we don't know why
you know the fine structure constant
which as you know is a ratio
of electric charge and planck's constant
the speed of light
we don't know why it has the value 1
over 137
at particular energy scales we don't
know why
and that's one of the deep questions
that we hope one day to answer
but as of today we don't look one answer
i should say
a far out answer is that maybe we live
in a multiverse
right maybe we live in a multiverse how
does that help
well remember what the multiverse is
right i can even show you a
little kind of picture of the multiverse
i think right
so right so there's the multiverse
so each of those spheres represents
a different universe and our universe
would be
one sphere in this grand collection
of of different spheres different
universes now why is that relevant to
the question that was asked
well imagine that in each of those
universes
the constants of nature may still be
constant but they might have different
values
and that would mean that the
values and the dimensionless ratios
that's an environmental feature of the
world it's not a fundamental feature of
the world it depends on which
of these bubbles you're in which of the
spheres
which of the universes in the multiverse
you
happen to inhabit and that's one
possible answer
and that answer would be there's no
fundamental explanation of the
fundamental constants of nature they
vary from universe to universe
and perhaps the values that they have in
our universe
are special because they allow for the
chemical and biological and physical
processes necessary for our form of life
so maybe the answer is not some
fundamental physics explanation but
rather the concepts of nature have the
values they do because
when they have different values as they
may in other universes
highly speculative idea those universes
aren't planets and people
so the answer might be one of
environmental
influence as opposed to some sort of
fundamental first principle explanation
for why the constants have the values
that they do and being told i'm out of
focus on my
webcam needs to refocus on me i don't
know how to do that
guys but uh now i can sort of try
to do that you know i'm not a
particularly
good person when it comes to these kinds
of things but
let me shut off the autofocus turn on
the focus
i don't know that looks pretty good so
let me know if that helps guys because
it's kind of irritating to uh
to view things that are blurry for the
next period of time that we have
together hopefully that helped
but um let me know in the chat or
wherever you can i'd appreciate that
okay so carrying on with your questions
kirag oh come on that was a good
question and now
i touched my scroll and it ran away from
me
i'm so sad that was a good multiverse
question
perfect question to go into um okay i'm
told
at least that i fixed the the focus
problem so let me know if that happens
again um so correct ask your question
again it's somewhere in the
in the in the feed and i lost it i think
it was a multiverse question
um akash shaylar asks is the universe
expanding at different rates
at different locations and it depends
what you mean by universe here by
universe you mean
you know the multiverse which again i'm
not saying that there is a multiverse
but it's an interesting idea worthy of
consideration
then of course in the different
universes space could expand at
different rates
in our universe as far as we know as far
as you know the observations
seem to strongly suggest that our
universe is isotropic
isotropic means that regardless of the
direction that you're looking
the physical features the physical
properties on
average are the same and that suggests
that the rate of expansion
in the different three dimensions that
we know about
those rates are the same and they're
also the same
in the sense of homogeneity namely
regardless of where you
are the expansion rate is the same so
homogeneity and isotropy
lead to the conclusion that the
expansion of space is the same
regardless of where you are
located and what direction you are
measuring but you know in a theory like
string theory
which has extra dimensions i wish i had
some extra dimensions
stuff that i could show you but i don't
have anything
in my little goodie bag over here at the
moment
but by the way should tell me if you
enjoyed these these visuals
you know i thought it'd be kind of fun
to spice things
up for this launch of world science you
which is a highly highly visual platform
for discussing all these ideas not just
relativity but
you know cosmology and consciousness and
neuroscience
symmetry again you should really check
out world
science you because uh it's a great
opportunity to learn from
from the great thinkers of the world but
um in it's such a visual platform that i
thought it'd be fun to introduce
some visuals normally i'll just show you
my real background right here that you
see
you know behind me right now it's sort
of a a nice day
out there today but i don't have any
extra dimension stuff to show you maybe
next time but you should tell me
do you find the visuals fun in this
context or do you find them irritating
so
kind of just let me know on that in the
chat i'd be interested to know but the
reason i bring up extra dimensions
relevant to this question
of the expansion of space it's certainly
possible
that in the very early universe all the
dimensions assuming string theory is
right
so the three dimensions of space that we
know about together with the extra
dimensions of space that strengthen
requires imagine that they were all very
tiny early on
and imagine much in line with the
question that was asked
the rate of expansion of those
dimensions was
different imagine that the three big
dimensions that we know about you know
left right back forth up down
that these three big dimensions expanded
far more quickly
than the rate of expansion of the other
dimensions
of space and that's why we are all
familiar
with the three big dimensions of common
experience because they grew
large enough that we have direct access
to them
through our vision through our eyes
and imagine that the other dimensions
are just as real
but they either didn't expand at all or
they expanded so
slowly that they're still so tiny that
we don't have direct
access to them through everyday
experience through our eyes
so that would be a nice application of
the question
to give an explanation for how it's
possible
in a theory that posits
more than three dimensions of common
experience how it's possible
that we would only be aware of three of
those dimensions a subset of those
dimensions
one possible answer is what the
questioner asked
the answer might be that the three
dimensions you know that expanded much
more quickly than the others and that's
why
they're much easier to see all right
what else do we have in our question
scroll here
sun jal prasad asks
from the world science festival webpage
do you think that time travel to the
past is possible
and i don't know about time travel to
the past
i would say that the best answer as of
today is that time travel to the past
has not been ruled out
it's a real possibility in the sense
that
the door has not been firmly shut
and that means that creative individuals
may find a way of
walking through that tiny crack in
understanding and one day establishing
the time travel to the past as possible
if you ask me though to go a little bit
beyond what we
absolutely know and to
speculate my guess is that time travel
to the past is not possible
my guess is that time travel to the past
will
one day be ruled out fully firmly done
but time travel to the future which you
didn't ask about because i suspect you
know the answer
time travel to the future is possible
it's exactly what i was
saying early on when we talk about time
slowing down for a clock that's
in motion right you put that clock on a
rocket ship it goes out
it comes back less time will have a
lapse on that round-trip
journey than on your clock on planet
earth so when that space
traveler steps out of the portal in that
rocket ship
they will have aged less than you they
will have aged
less than all of earth has aged what
does that mean that means they have
jumped into the future
to jump into the future simply to
find yourself in a circumstance where
the environment around you has aged much
more
than you have literally in the sense
that the amount of time that's gone by
one year for you but a million years for
everybody else
means that you have jumped into the
future by roughly a million
years or 999 999 years
that's what it means and that is within
the understanding of physics as we know
it
another interesting question along these
lines
giannis asks on the world science
festival page
so if you go to the past you go to your
own past or in a parallel universe past
and that's a that's a very important
question to ask again number one i don't
know if it's possible to go to the past
number two i don't even know if there
are other universes so
speculation one and speculation too but
be that
as it may let's carry on and imagine
what the possibilities might be
and people have speculated that if you
could travel to the past
you would go to the past in a parallel
universe not in your own
simply because that's a way of getting
around this famous grandfather
or grandmother paradox remember what
that paradox is
if you can go to the past
and perhaps prevent your grandparents
from
ever meeting then
you would never be born right
because your parents would never be born
you know so
if that's the case how are you ever
there to
effectuate the change that kept your
parents or grandparents from meeting in
the first place
that's the paradox how do you solve that
paradox well
as giannis asks if when you travel to
the past
if you can you find yourself always
in a parallel universe not the universe
from which you originated
then the question of your birth no
longer poses a paradox you were born in
universe number one
you traveled to the past in universe two
in universe two your grandparents never
met
your parents never met you were never
born in universe two
but that's not paradoxical any longer
because you were born in universe one
your origin is no longer cause
for consternation if
when you travel to the past you travel
always to a parallel universe so that's
why people talk about
this idea and yeah you know
it's it's not ruled out
people have used ideas of special and
general relativity to even
suggest ways you might travel to the
past
but as yet i'd say it's highly
highly highly speculative
and again my gut feeling is that one day
will be ruled out
okay so let me just carry on with some
of the
questions in the live chat
claudio barrosa asks how do you know if
a body is stationary not moving in the
universe and the answer
is let me give two answers to that
number one fundamentally speaking there
is no answer
in the sense of there's no absolute
notion of rest
so the only time that you can really
ever talk
about speed is when you're talking about
the speed of one object
relative to another so you can't say
that an object is moving in the universe
period end of story
you can say object number one is moving
relative to object number two
you can the object number two is moving
relative to object number three but if
these objects in principle
are moving at a fixed speed in a fixed
direction and they always have been and
they always will be then each of those
objects can claim to be at rest
can claim to be stationary and claim
that the motion
that's taking place is motion relative
to
their perspective to their frame of
reference
and that's something that every object
moving at a fixed speed and fixed
direction can
validly claim now why do i say fix speed
and fix direction because if it's not
fixed speed in a fixed direction if
there's acceleration or deceleration
which can be speeding up or slowing down
or going around a bend not in a fixed
direction
then that object can feel intrinsically
that motion
and that object therefore can claim to
be in motion
and cannot claim to be at rest to came
to claim to be at rest
you have got to satisfy certain
conditions
which roughly speaking can be summarized
by saying
that you don't feel any motion
otherwise you are absolutely
in motion but there's no notion of
absolute rest
now i said i was going to give two
answers the second answer is well
practically speaking what do we mean for
instance about the age of the universe
when we say that has a particular age
13.8 billion years right on whose clock
and the answer to that is it's on those
clocks
for whom the observer moving with that
clock would see the cosmic microwave
background to be homogeneous and
isotropic
that it won't have a preferred
orientation moving with respect to the
cosmic microwave background radiation so
in a certain sense cosmologically
speaking there is a
preferred frame of reference it's that
one
for which the background radiation has
that
particular property but putting
cosmology to the side just thinking
about an object moving through space
no preferred frame of reference no
absolute notion
of being at rest okay
let me go back to the the feed here
charles moorer asks if time stopped and
reversed
direction how would we ever know
wouldn't we
unremember all those moments couldn't
time always be moving back
and forth and and
the basic point that you make charles is
an absolutely valid one
the individual if
the change in time
speeding up or slowing down is a true
property of the physical universe
and if that individual's thoughts are
nothing but a product of the physical
processes within that physical universe
then the individual never experiences
time doing anything odd right
i mean you're going back and forth and
remembering un remembering
that's a little bit more complex and
it's a little bit more subtle but you
can ask the same question
using the special theory of relativity
example that
i was giving you before i mean look if
someone is carrying this clock
in motion right so the clock
is in motion and time is slowing down
from our stationary perspective on that
moving clock you can see it it's ticking
off time more slowly
what about the individual that's moving
with that moving clock well they
experience time slowing down
answer to that question is they won't
experience time
slowing down at all because
when we talk about the light clock
showing less elapsed time we're talking
about time
real time and
because we're talking about real time it
applies not just to the light clock
that's slowing but it applies to
biological processes chemical processes
physical processes
neurological processes so the individual
carrying
that light clock in motion the
neurological processes responsible for
their experience will slow down
their thoughts will slow down
and therefore as they look for instance
at their clock
they look at their environment
it will appear to them
that nothing has happened if they look
back and by comparison look at our
stationary clock
they will say that our stationary clock
has slowed down
but their intrinsic experience
the number of books that they could read
in their lifetime
will be the same regardless of whether
they
were with us sitting still
or with that moving clock
their life will elapse in slow motion
and they won't feel it they won't know
it because their thoughts
are slowing down too because their
thoughts are a physical process
so in that sense the individual without
reference to other external
points of comparison the individual
does not experience say the slowing
or the speeding up of time
so coco coco has come back with a
follow-on question i like follow-on
questions
and coco says but sir why does a second
manifest a bit more than a second
on a moving clock wouldn't that imply
that more time has passed for the moving
being than in one second of the
non-moving one yeah this is always a
point of confusion
and when we say
that time has slowed down on the moving
clock here's what we really mean what we
really mean is
for that moving clock to go tick tock
okay and thereby register one
on the counter on that moving clock tick
tock
we look at our stationary clock and say
our stationary tacos tick tock and a
little bit more
so more than one second goes by on our
stationary clock
when one second has gone by
on the moving clock that's the sense in
which time
is slowing down on the moving clock
it takes more than one second for its
clock
to go tick-tock why because it's ticking
off time more slowly that's the
colloquial language you say
it's ticking off time more slowly
because going tick
tock well our clock is going tick tock
tick tock
tick tock that's a sense in which less
time elapses on the moving clock i hope
that addresses the question coco coco
but
come back at me if i missed point
or if you're not convinced by that
explanation
all right i'm scrolling through some of
the live chat questions
and chris arun asks what has that to do
with age
and i say chris that has everything to
do with
age age
is nothing but a reflection
of the physical processes that are
taking place in your body
and if those physical processes are
taking place at a slower rate
then you are aging more slowly so if i'm
looking at you carrying that moving
light clock
just that we can have a very specific
image in mind
i look at the light clock in motion and
it's going tick
tock because the light's going on that
double diagonal that
longer trajectory at the same speed so
i'm watching your
moving light clock is going tick tock i
conclude therefore
that time is slowing down for you in
motion and that
time refers to
true time it's time
it's not some weird thing that a light
clock measures
it's what we mean by duration and
therefore if time is slowing down
then the molecular processes in your
body
are slowing down the neurological
processes in your brain
are slowing down the rate at which you
are
aging is slowing down
and that's why this has everything to do
with age i mean sometimes people
they understand the light clock
but they leave the example thinking that
it's just some weird
property of some weird contraption that
happens to have two
mirrors mounted in a parallel manner
facing each other with a ball of light
bouncing in between
but it's not just some weird feature
of some arbitrary gadget what we're
actually
tapping into is the rate at which time
itself is elapsing
and the light clock is merely a simple
tool
to measure the rate at which time is
elapsing we could do with any watch
grandfather clock rolex watch
the clock on your iphone it doesn't
matter the only reason i use the light
clock is because
the inner mechanism is so fantastically
simple that with a little animation and
a little thought we can
conclude that the tick tock on the
moving like clock
is going slower it's the simplification
of the inner mechanism that allows us to
do that but
although the journey would be more
complicated we can do the same thing
for any clock regardless of the
mechanism it's just harder to come to
the conclusion
and i'm in favor of easier ways of
getting to deep conclusions than hard
ways
to get at deep conclusions and that's
why we use the light clock
but don't be fooled into thinking that
the conclusion is somehow only relevant
to the light clock the conclusion is
relevant to
time itself you want an argument for
that
i'll give you an argument for that take
your iphone
give it to me yeah give it to me now
okay i'm gonna take your iphone
and i'm gonna strap it to the top of
that
light clock and i'm going to set that
like clock
in motion or assume that's always been
in motion so i don't have to deal with
acceleration but don't worry about those
details
if you are now walking along with
your iphone and the light clock
from your perspective you can claim that
you are at rest and everything else is
moving relative to you
right fixed speed and fixed direction
you can claim to be at rest and because
you can claim to be at rest
you of course are going to say that the
tick tock of the light clock and the
tick tock
on your iphone are in sync we've set it
up so they're in sync
and because you can now draw that
conclusion
we who are watching you in motion
say aha the phone the iphone clock and
the light clock
clock they are in sync and therefore if
the light clock
slows down the iphone must be slowing
down too because they are in sync
you've already established that by
virtue of
your ability to claim that you
the light clock and the iphone are all
at rest and everybody else is moving
relative to you and how could
any external motion affect the
synchronization of your iphone
and the light clock and therefore the
slowing of time on the light
clock is the slowing of time on the
iphone
is the slowing of time on each
and every clock so again i mean clocks
they come in you know all sorts of
shapes
all sorts of styles you know
you know here's a kind of fun little
animation
showing the kinds of clocks that we have
invented
over the course of
our species right from sundials
to old-fashioned alarm clocks
you know to quartz crystals to whatever
my claim is
the conclusion that we reached
regarding the slowing of time in the
light clock it applies to each and every
one of the clocks that you are
seeing and each and every one of the
clocks that you can imagine
as long as that clock
is indeed ticking off in a regular
manner
as long as that clock is somehow
advancing forward in a
regular manner equal intervals between
the numbers or the ticks or the blips
whatever mechanism it uses
all of that will be happening slower if
that clock is in motion relative to us
if we're looking at that clock in motion
we will conclude
the time is elapsing slower on that
clock
than on ours it is a completely
general conclusion about the nature
of time so chris that's uh chris arun
maybe that was a
more involved answer than you
anticipated but i hope that convinces
you that
what we're talking about with the
special theory of relativity
has everything to do with age because it
has everything to do
with time
all righty so i'm going to continue our
session our your daily equation session
but i wanted to kind of draw a little
bit of a break between
the world science u live session
focusing upon the specialty of
relativity and i really do encourage you
guys to check out my course there
at world science u which explains all
these ideas and somebody asked if
there's
the math behind it and there is so
there's two versions
of the course the one at the moment
that's up there
is the non-mathematical version that
explains
the ideas in the kinds of language that
we're using here today
but those of you who like math and i
know some of you do
the math version of that will be
reposted
it's been up before but it's going to be
reposted in a
newly revamped and refined architecture
for the experience so i think you'll
enjoy that
and over there's five courses there
right now and over we're going to be
releasing new classes about
i think on the order of one per week for
the next 30 or 40 weeks
and the faculty is you know second to
none some of the great thinkers
in the world so you should go check it
out world science you but i'm not going
to
segue a little bit to focus on
yeah if you want to ask relativity
questions more than happy to but i
would now like to address any and all
questions
that you might have in mind
so just throw them at me and i'm happy
to uh
to field as many as
i can all right so um
what do we have here
uh the ubos asked dr bo's request to
comment
on if a potential imaging technique can
be devised to select cancers
over non-cancer cells and i would say
dr bose thanks for your question it's
not my field of expertise i can't really
help you there i mean you all know that
the way you know mris
work is by using
the ability to modify
the spins of particles in a magnetic
field
and to thereby
access the qualities of human tissue
based upon the kinds of
blood flow that they support and doctors
and researchers have gotten very good
at distinguishing different kinds of
tissues
by virtue of the different kinds of
signals that they
yield inside a magnetic
resonant imaging device but beyond that
unfortunately dr bose you're at a level
of medical detail
that is beyond my knowledge so i'll
encourage you to ask that question
to somebody who's in the medical field
suman acharya asks is time and immersion
property what is your
thought and
you know it's a hard hard question and i
don't know
nobody does their
i guess my suspicion is that time is an
emergent property my suspicion is
that time is a very useful way to
organize
experience and that's why it naturally
emerged
in the course of our species and that's
why we all have
a deep intuition about time
right now the intuition is not accurate
when you're considering physical
situations that are remote
from human experience right so
near the speed of light who would have
thought that time slows down
and yet as we've been discussing it does
who would have thought that time
slows down near the edge of a black hole
we don't experience these things and
therefore
they lie outside the purview of our
intuition
so my guess is that
the qualities of time that we hold dear
and the ubiquity of time is an
organizing principle i mean we can't
even go half a sentence without talking
about
the past or the future or the present in
some way shape or form we conjugate
verbs based upon
the tense so we can't get out of a
temporal way of thinking about the world
and i suspect that's because that way of
thinking about the world had
evolutionary
advantages and we
therefore evolved in a way to
think about the world in temporal terms
but are there other ways to think about
the world
and is it possible to imagine a
non-temporal
way of thinking about the world is it
possible that time is emergent in this
sense
i think it's quite possible yes
all right um let's see
uh francis serafini
says if to coco if you see him as
blinking slower
he then has to see who is blinking
faster
and that's an interesting interesting
comment that is not completely true
actually
so you would have thought that in
special relativity let's be concrete
that if you see me blinking slower
because i'm in motion and you're
watching me and
time for me from your perspective is
slowing down
you would think therefore that the
symmetry of the situation
might suggest that you see me slower i
see you faster and that's not right
so if i am moving away from you
i can equally claim that you're moving
away from me and then the symmetry of
the situation is even more deep than you
would have thought based upon
a cursory analysis of the situation
everything that you did to conclude
that i am in slow motion whether it's
through observation or mathematical
calculation
i can do regarding you and so you will
see me blink
slowly and i will see you blink slowly
not faster
and that is a curious quality of the
situation now there's something else
that i should bring up
which is a little bit confusing but keep
your head on straight
if i am not moving away from you but
rather i am moving toward you
then the intrinsic effect of time
slowing down
because i'm a body in motion and you're
watching me
that is overwhelmed as it turns out by
a separate but related effect the
doppler effect
where the light that's traveling from me
to your eyeballs
has to travel an ever less
distance has to travel an ever shorter
distance from my face say to your eyes
as i'm approaching you
and that shortened distance that the
light travels
makes it appear that i'm speeding up
right because as i'm blinking the light
from when my eye is open
and the light from when my eye closes
the light from my closes doesn't have to
travel as far therefore it
in some sense gets to you more quickly
than it otherwise would if i were
stationary
so as i'm traveling toward you you will
see my eyes
blink more quickly and i will see your
eyes bring
blink more quickly now you might think
that that would suggest that time is
speeding up
but it's not if we carefully unravel
our observations of the eye blinking
more quickly we will realize
the time intrinsically is slowing down
but this doppler effect of the light
having to travel a shorter distance
makes it appear as though
my eyes are blinking more quickly
so and it's again completely symmetric i
see you blinking more quickly you see me
blinking more quickly in the reverse not
the reverse
but if i'm moving away you'll see my
eyes blink more slowly i will see your
eyes blink more
slowly perfect symmetry you might say
well okay then how does this
answer the twin paradox it does in a
very beautiful and simple
way maybe i'll leave it to one of the
views to uh to give
that answer in fact maybe i'll bring in
some visuals next time to show that
bottom line is just for you who are
interested and this actually is
covered in one of the modules in the
special relativity course
to the person in motion half of the
journey
if they had a powerful telescope look
back on planet earth
half of the journey they'll see my eyes
blinking
slowly and half namely on the return
they'll see my eyes blinking
more quickly for the person on earth
namely me looking at the space travel
let's say it's you
i will see your eyes blinking slowly for
a much longer fraction of the journey
than one half
why when you turn around and come back
i don't see that you've turned around
yet
because the light from your turn around
has to travel all the way back to my
eyeballs for me to see it
so it takes a long time for me to
recognize that you've turned around
which means it takes a long time for me
to see your eyes
blinking quickly so for the majority of
your round trip journey i see your eyes
blinking slowly and just for a little
bit at the end i see your eyes blinking
more quickly
which means overall i will have seen you
more in slow motion than in fast motion
you will have aged as i watch you less
than you will have seen me age for half
of my
time half of the journey i'm slow and
half i'm quick
it's theirs where the asymmetry comes in
the person who's actually in motion has
to turn around and come back and when
they turn
around they immediately know that
they've turned around they felt the
motion and they immediately are
encountering
light signals that are
subject to this blue shift the subject
of this lorentz
this doppler effect that's the
difference that's where the asymmetry
comes into the story if that's confusing
to you
don't be upset it's a complex idea
i spell it out visually on world science
you so again not to plug it too much but
worth checking that out okay
ellen asks is math brain a myth can an
adult still learn
and it's half a myth and half
not a myth ellen i would say so
it's not that the adult brain can't
somehow learn things that the younger
brain can it's just harder
i found for the adult brain to do so and
certain tasks
you know neuroscientists have studied
the plasticity
of the brain and the brain is more able
to take in
novel behaviors and novel concepts when
it's in its most formative
stages and therefore you know we see it
you want to learn piano
do it as a kid i tell this to my kids
all the time and they roll their eyes
which hurts me to my core because
you all know you've met so many people
maybe you yourself
have fretted over the fact that you gave
up piano you say why did i do that
because now when you try to go back it's
so much more difficult
so much more difficult because your
brain doesn't have the plasticity that
it once did and therefore it's harder
for
it to learn new tricks so
there's something to be said about that
for mathematics i mean
math prodigies have the ability to
absorb
math at an astounding rate and i don't
know a single example of a math prodigy
whose prodigious talents emerged in
adulthood
i mean maybe there are examples i'd be
interested to hear about it
but i don't know of an example and it
kind of makes sense to me because the
brain is more
set in its structural form after
whatever i don't know what the age is
called
20 or 20 plus years and it makes it
harder for that brain
to do the kinds of things that a younger
brain does with ease so ellen yes you
can learn math
at an older age it's just more difficult
one amelica asks if two objects in space
move away from each other and we don't
know which one is actually moving
who is time going to slow for and i love
the question one
amelka because it highlights it i don't
i don't mean this in
a mean sense but it highlights a real
confusion that many people have not just
you
look at the language that you're using
one amelca
you see if two objects in space are
moving away from each other and we don't
know which one
is actually moving you have in mind that
there's a notion
of absolute motion and absolute rest
and there isn't there is no notion of
which is actually moving again i'm
assuming fixed speed fixed direction you
know they're moving
away from each other like this there is
no
absolute answer to the question of who
is actually moving
they're moving relative to each other
and what that means is
if one of those objects looks at the
other
this observer will say that that
observer's clock is taking off time
slowly
if that observer looks back at the first
object that observer will say that the
other observer
has a clock that's taking up time
more slowly and that's it
there's no absolute notion of time
there is no absolute notion of time
slowing down that
has in mind there's some grand cosmic
clock in the newtonian sense
that's the real clock that really
measures time and we are
comparing to it but there is no such
cosmic universal time there is no such
cosmic clock it is time
from one person's perspective relative
to time from another's perspective
and that's it there's no notion of
absolute rest there's no notion of
absolute constant velocity
there's no notion of absolute time it's
always
one relative to another
okay let me uh
see what else we have here
um zero oscar asks why do you use
newtonian gravity and
einsteinian gravitation as
interchangeable terms
oh i hope i don't i hope i don't
when i'm talking about newtonian gravity
i'm talking about
the kind of gravity described by f
equals g m one m two over r
squared it's gravity that exerts and
influence instantaneous
across any distance and it's the
version of gravity that was put down in
the late 1600s when i talk about
einsteinian gravity
i'm talking about gravity that follows a
different equation r mu nu minus a half
g me new arc was 8 pi g over c to the
fourth t mu nu
einstein's field equations and it's a
version of gravity
that differs from the newtonian one
in situations that involve large speeds
large velocities
and exceedingly large gravitational
fields like those of a black hole so
if i've given you the impression that
i'm conflating
newtonian gravity and einsteinian
gravity i apologize for that
i'd like to know further where you
thought i was conflating them because at
least in my mind
maybe not in my language i keep them
quite separate quite distinct
okay
gcell asks is it possible that the speed
of light in the far
future is faster and and yes there are
people who have
discussed what are known as vsls
variable speed of light theories
and they've exacted a degree of
controversy from the community
but the notion that the speed of light
at one moment and the speed of light at
another moment might be
different values seems to me
a logically possible way
that the world could behave speed of
light you measure it
on whatever you know july 23rd
2020 you measure the speed of light on
july 24
2020 and you take the ratio of those
numbers
and it seems logically possible that
that ratio would not be equal to one
and some have wondered if
the speed of light was very different in
the early universe
whether it might help address certain
cosmological
puzzles that we have fretted over
i don't think these theories have really
gathered a great deal of support
in the physics community largely because
there's no evidence for the speed of
light
changing over time but as a logical
possibility yeah
i think it is an absolute logical
possibility
um
a l a asks professor are dimensionless
physical constants rational or
irrational and
i see no reason why these ratios can't
be
irrational you know when we measure
a physical quantity using a real device
you know we measure it to a certain
degree of accuracy
and therefore we measure it as
a real number to a finite number of
decimal places which means of course we
measure a rational number and therefore
when we take the ratio of two
measured constants of nature it's
irrational over a rational so it would
be
i hope i said that clearly it's a
rational divided by
another rational and therefore that
quotient is also
an a rational number not an
rational number but
those are just measurements i don't see
any fundamental reason
why the constants of nature might not be
like pi
or e and therefore
irrational so in answer to your question
i don't see any reason why they can't be
irrational but maybe if you have an
argument
otherwise i certainly would be
game to hear it all right um
charles maurer if we looked at a black
hole shouldn't we see everything that
has ever fallen into it around the event
horizon
aren't we seeing those objects time
approach zero and the answer that is yes
so from the perspective of somebody
outside of a black hole watching an
object heading toward a black hole
you're absolutely right that
much is in the light clock in motion
although the argument
is more involved but similar to that
you would find that time on a clock
of an object heading toward the event
horizon of a black hole
would tick off ever more slowly and
as that object got right to the horizon
the rate at which his clock would tick
would approach zero
you're absolutely right so from our
perspective watching it it's as if the
object
not just goes in slow motion as it's
approaching the enterprise actually
freezes now why don't we see that well
[Music]
the light that the object gives off
has oscillations that go ever more
slowly which means a wavelength that
grows ever longer which means that it's
redshifted
in fact as it approaches the edge of a
black hole
the light that we receive from that
object is infinitely
red shifted which means that it becomes
increasingly difficult to actually see
that object so in some sense
all the objects that fall into a black
hole from our perspective
are there on the horizon but they're so
redshifted that we can't ever see them
now again that's a very different story
from the perspective
of the object itself from its
perspective
it's just going along and it crosses the
event to rise and it falls in and gets
crushed at the singularity according to
the classical general theory of
relativity
so again it's two very different
perspectives
they're mutually compatible but the
stories that we tell are
are quite different from one another and
that's the lesson
of relativity we have to admit distinct
narratives describing reality they can't
be
mutually contradictory narratives but
they can be different
narratives and here's an example where
the narratives are quite different
they're not contradictory as i've
described it
people have tried to find contradictions
and interesting
insights have emerged from the studies
and that's a whole different story
but there are different narratives
describing reality
based on the perspective that you take
okay carry on um
so gokul oh i had a i'm sorry
monjeb's tv when two particles are
collided
some of their energy is lost where does
it go
could it go to another dimension if yes
then is it possible that some energy may
come
from another dimension to our dimension
and in brief the answer is yes to all
those questions in fact one of the ways
that we'd hope
to gain experimental evidence for the
existence
of other dimensions is through
proton proton collisions at the large
hadron collider
the hope monjeb's tv is exactly
the question that you've articulated the
hope was
that proton against proton slam together
very high speed and some of the debris
from the collision
according to the math of string theory
might be ejected
out of our three-dimensional spacing get
crammed into
another dimension of space how would we
notice that
well you measure the energy just before
the collision
you measure the energy remaining after
the collision and if some of that
energy has disappeared into another
dimension you'll have more energy before
the conclusion
collision than after it missing energy
signature
now we looked for those and we have yet
to find any missing energy signatures
what does that mean
number one it could be string theory is
wrong
it could be that there aren't extra
dimensions
simple explanation it could also be
however
that there are extra dimensions it's
just that they're
so tightly curled up that the energy
that you need
to get into them to seep into them is
larger than
the energy of the large hazard on
collider
and that's why we haven't seen any
missing energy signatures
or you know it could be that well there
are a host of other possibilities but
let me
leave it at those two and there
by pivot to the second half of your
question which is
if in principle energy could go into the
extra dimensions if the large hadron
collider was bigger if the extra
dimensions were larger
could it be that energy could come the
other direction in principle yeah
in principle yes in principle you could
have energy
seeping in energy that we aren't
cognizant
of in our three big dimensions could
show up
and uh that's a possibility now don't go
crazy on this idea
this doesn't mean all of a sudden that
the ideas that you see in science
fiction where somebody
you know snaps a finger and they
disappear you say oh
that's scientific because what happens
is their energy went into another
dimension no it's not as though
these possibilities can be realized
in familiar physical situations we're
talking about extreme physical
situations
but in those extreme situations yes
energy can pop in
from another dimension
okay let's see um
so kirag baltha
shirag balfa asks are other universes
also having the same speed of light
since the speed of light is constant and
and i don't know the answer to that
question
number one as i mentioned before the
speed of light in principle can vary
in our universe there are there are
theories that have been written down
these variable speed of light theories
that i've mentioned
and so you know even in a situation
that's not as exotic
as you know the one that you talk about
so
you know here's another way of thinking
about
the multiverse so imagine that there's a
big bang that yields you know the grand
expanse of everything and within
that grand expanse imagine that little
pockets
open up where the energy transforms into
particles
and each of those dark regions would be
a universe now that's a very exotic idea
and if the speed of light can vary in
our universe then you can certainly
imagine it varying across
the multiverse but a a related question
that
that perhaps is more insightful
is to ask what about the dimensionless
ratios like the mass of this particle
to that particle to that vary across the
multiverse and the answer that is
is surely yes and our theories allow for
that
kind of thing to happen and as i
mentioned before
that maybe gives us an explanation for
why those dimensionless ratios have the
values that they do it's a different
kind of answer
it's an environmental answer it's not an
answer where we say
the mass of this particle to that
particle had to be this value because
of pure logic or the only
logically consistent theory of the
universe demands that that ratio have
this particular value that'd be a very
convincing
and satisfying explanation but we don't
have any evidence that our theories
have the power to yield that kind of
explanation so the reverse explanation
championed by people like lenny suskind
is that those dimensionless ratios vary
from universe to universe across the
multiverse
and the value that those ratios have in
our universe
is simply the value as i mentioned
before that allows for the physical
properties and chemical processes and
biological development that yields human
beings and life as we know it
and the answer therefore for why the
ratios have the values they do is
much more situational we are here and
observe those values because those
values
are such that the physical and
biological and chemical processes
necessary for our form of life can take
place
so that would be a distinct way of
thinking about
the explanation for the dimensionless
constants of nature
um
josh antencio asks when you die
will you promise to let us know if there
is
an afterlife and um josh you've got my
word
if it's possible for me to let you know
that there is no you know what josh i'm
going to take that back
think there must be something powerful
about not knowing the answer to that
question
and i would not want to somehow
eliminate the mystery of life after
death from
all human discourse so i'm going to
leave that as a mystery you're going to
have to get the promise from
somebody else um
vishvesh patel asks what mechanism at
the quantum level gives light its speed
what gives the photon the push from zero
to c
instantaneously the photon when born
wouldn't have speed
instinctively and i'm answer those
questions in reverse i would say the
photon does
have the speed c instinctively
i would say that there is no notion of a
photon speeding up from zero to c
photons as disturbances
in the electromagnetic field those
disturbances
always end forever travel at the speed
of light
so there's no notion of an
electromagnetic disturbance of the sort
that isn't traveling at
the speed of light but then you say you
know how to explain this at the quantum
level look we have quantum
electrodynamics
within quantum electrodynamics we have a
quanta
a minimum excitation a minimum quantum
excitation
of the electromagnetic field that we
call a photon
and within quantum electrodynamics you
see directly that
the speed of this disturbance will be
equal to
the speed of light and the speed of
light being
the number that emerges say from
maxwell's equations
by considering the permeability and the
permittivity of free space
and that ratio gives you the speed of
light and indeed it's a ratio that comes
right
out of quantum electrodynamics
so i don't know if that's a satisfying
answer but that's
one rigorous way that we can think about
photons as disturbances as quanta
that have a very specific speed
what happens to light after we switch
off a bulb as energy can't be created
nor
destroyed and the answer to that is
when we turn off a light bulb we are no
longer
exciting the electromagnetic field
and therefore we are no longer emitting
photons from
the bulb so as long as the the bulb is
on as long as current is flowing through
we're able to excite the electromagnetic
field and
the result is a torrent of photons that
are emitted by that process turn off the
bulb and you turn
off the process you turn off the
emission
of new photons that's all there is to it
um neutrino says no there is no god
sorry you may be right neutrino
so we sometimes talk about those issues
here i'm not going to talk about it
right now
um but you may be right
um let's see if there's something on the
wsu
page oh yeah a bunch of questions there
[Music]
sam wilcox on the world science u
page asks if past present and future
all exist simultaneously parenthetically
which
i still have not understood exactly
doesn't mean
we have no free will our future is fixed
and uh in answer to the free will
question
yeah you do not have free will
i would say that your future is fixed
though in the sense that
you're a collection of particles
governed by quantum mechanical laws and
the quantum mechanical laws
only describe the probability
of one or other future for your
collection of particles
so if that's what you mean by your
future is fixed
namely the probabilities of this or that
eventuality
are fixed yeah the probabilities are
fixed
but the eventuality what actually
happens is not fixed
so even though you don't have free will
even though you're fully governed by the
mathematical laws that describe how your
particles behave and
interact even though you don't have free
will i would say that your
future in the conventional intuitive
sense
of what will actually happen is not
fixed so it's kind of an in-between
place you don't have any choice you
don't have any control
you don't have any willful ability to
determine what will happen
even though what will happen is not
determined
as yet because the physics only
determines the probabilities of getting
one or another outcome
now you'll notice that i didn't rely
upon the first part of your question
the first part of your question was if
past present and future all exist
simultaneously
then does it mean that i don't have free
will my argument that you don't have
free will
is more general than the one that you're
anticipating but the one you're
anticipating is compatible
with this idea because
if the future exists now that's a
classical sense in which it exists
special relativity is a classical theory
so in the sense of special relativity
that the future exists
because my future might be your past
and therefore your past has already
happened
and therefore in some sense my future
has already happened because it
coincides with your past that we are in
relative emotion
so yeah i mean the so-called block
universe picture
that this yields does have a future that
is set in stone so
but i would say in a classical world if
you're willing to go be classical which
is what this is
i would say you're done with free will
from the get-go
because in the classical world you give
me the state of the world now
and i'll tell you the state of the world
later and therefore your will has
nothing to do with the state of the
world
later your will is part of the unfolding
it's part of the sequence of events that
gets us from here
to there or perhaps i should say from
now to then
but it is not as though you freely exert
your will
allowing you to contravene
the mechanistic development from today
till then
so in a classical world it's done
there's simply no
free will in a quantum world some people
argue
there's a little bit of room i don't
think there's any room at all
because if your will can't determine the
outcome
of the quantum events then you don't
have
free will but it is the case that there
is
greater flexibility regarding what
happens
because the quantum laws only predict
the probabilities
so good and subtle question
all right how are we doing here 4 30.
boy i don't have the stamina that's i do
have to build up
give these long sessions some of you may
know by the way
and i'd be interested to know in the
chat you know some of you know i did an
hour before this live session on reddit
you know this rpan reddit public access
network you know my book publisher
some of you know i had a book come out
in february until the end of time
they've been encouraging me to do some
of these
reddit sessions you know answer
questions about the book and other
things
so i did that from two o'clock eastern
time to three o'clock eastern time
and then our session is on the heels of
that session
every other week i may do that i'm not
completely sure how long i'll do that
but uh so this is now two and a half
hours for me so i'm going to try to go a
grand total of three hours
which would take us to five o'clock
which would be a good hour
less than the record that i've done in
the past
but um i'm feeling um
somewhat more exhausted although i'm
going to
pump up the energy for the last half
hour here
easy spark if you're tired we understand
thank you easy sparky but i'm going to
give it my all for the last half hour
so don't think that i'm going to somehow
shirk my responsibility here
um but let me find some good questions
that i haven't um
already addressed robinson
infant says are you here in new york
it's 4 35 p.m new york time
yes i'm here humans yes robinson i'm
i'm not in new york city but i'm outside
of new york city you have kind of a
as you can see it's kind of a a nice
space
up here in the catskill mountains
a little gentle breeze behind me which
is uh
kind of fun but uh
dang joe's i remember that name from
when we were doing these sessions
earlier and i touched my scroll and i
lost your question
dang jose but i remember it from a half
a second ago reading it quickly i
believe dangerous was asking
how does relativity work if you take
into account
that the speed of light in say water
is slower than the speed of light in a
vacuum
and and that's a well-known fact that
the speed of light
in a vacuum is different than the speed
of light in a medium be that water or
glass or
anything else and this has no
impact on any of the occlusion on any on
any of the conclusions
take a drink of water on that one any of
the conclusions
that we've been talking about it's a
well-known
fact that as light meanders through a
medium
that's populated with atoms
the transmission of the light through
that medium
is slower than it is through a medium
that isn't populated by
the collection of atoms so when i talk
about the speed of light being constant
and i talk about the speed of light
being whatever 300 millimeters per
second i'm talking about the speed of
light through a vacuum
so bear in mind that that's what i mean
when i make that statement
and the fact that the speed of light
differs
as speed traverses various media is well
understood
and it fits perfectly within our
relativistic description of things so
it doesn't in any way impact our
conclusions it just
enriches the
physical situations that we are able
to describe cosmic slice asks on one of
our platforms
did you borrow tracy's glasses again
and cosmic slice you have a keen sense
of the obvious
indeed i have i do have another pair
that i had around here
someplace but i couldn't find them so
in the last minute desire to be able to
see what's going on
i have stolen tracy my wife's glasses
again so thank you for pointing that out
cosmic slice
um keurig
i love the chemistry between you and dr
neil degrasse tyson well thank you i've
always enjoyed
being on neil's shows uh
he's a very energetic and very smart
individual
and always has great questions and
always makes it
an enjoyable journey that with that we
just go i think the last thing i did was
with him and chuck
nice i think i did yeah in in neil's
office just before the uh
just before the lockdown and the virus
hit maybe the last
thing that i did actually before the the
virus hit
and uh yeah we had a nice little session
which was actually talking about my book
oh
good gives me a nice segue back in so we
were talking about until the end of time
and we were taking audience questions on
the book and there were some great
questions so
so if you if you like neil and you like
the things that i talk about go check
out that segment
on star talk star talk cosmic
queries things called star talk cosmic
queries if i'm not mistaken
um okay um
andre zamfir hi professor could you
explain in a simple manner why m
theory requires 11 dimensions andre
unfortunately i cannot
i don't know how to do it i don't often
say that
sometimes i say we don't know the answer
that's different
that's where research hasn't progressed
to answer questions like
what was before the big bang
or the ratios of the fundamental
constants and so forth
questions which i think we one day will
answer but
when it comes to andre's question
i don't have a simple intuitive
explanation
for why m theory or string theory in
this more robust
setting requires 11 space space-time
dimensions
i can describe it mathematically and
roughly speaking the mathematics is very
straightforward
you look at certain equations but in the
theory
and you imagine that the universe has
any number of space-time dimensions and
you see that
the equations only make sense if you
have 11 space-time dimensions so it's an
internal mathematical consistency
argument that drives you to this
conclusion
but i agree that's not particularly
satisfying and when i wrote my first
book
the elegant universe i tried to answer
that question
and i felt that i couldn't and i was
upfront about that in the elegant
universe
and i've been upfront about it ever
since i can show you some nice visuals
and maybe i'll do it next time i don't
have any queued up so it's hard for me
to
grab them quickly but i'll show you some
visuals of
extra dimension in fact i have a video
out there right now
i don't know how i could show it to you
probably can't but i do have a video on
on
hyperspace i'm building four dimensional
spaces and five dimensional spaces you
can find it on youtube
i think it's on the world science
festival youtube page i don't i don't
have the link
maybe uh maybe someone can send me that
link
in in in one of these pages and i can
then post it in the chat
that'd be kind of i've never done that
before yeah in fact sometimes
people say that i'm i'm not me and and
i'll just tell you i
am me here i am writing
in the chat all right so there you go so
i just uh
i think there may be a time delay
between what i say within the chat
but there you go so that truly is me and
if
if one of our folks would give us the
link to this video this youtube video
which i show how to go from a point to a
line to a square to a cube to a hyper
cube
you know tesseract to a penter act and
and higher dimensional versions of those
shapes
but i i can't explain to you why it is
that
in an intuitive way beyond using that
mathematical explanation
for why it is that we need extra
dimensions in
in string and m theory uh eddie
hernandez can you come and give a
lecture at cal
tech sometime in 2021 yeah i'd love to
i you know eddie like everybody else i
don't know what the heck the world's
going to be like
in the near term or even the time scale
that you're talking about
you know it's it's it's it's leaders who
don't understand
science or who willfully ignore science
or who put
politics above science have gotten us
into
a tragic situation
especially in this country right i mean
other countries some are having trouble
too but many other countries they looked
at the situation and they dealt with it
they listened to the scientists and the
medical professionals and they dealt
with it but what did we do in this
country some officials did that here we
are in new york
state cuomo did a good job
listen to the medical professionals
listen to the science and you see the
curve
boom nice and down other states
georgia florida texas
didn't listen to the science didn't
listen to the medical professionals open
too soon and look at what's happening
and look
a country is a country there are no
borders in any real
sense we are literally in this together
in the sense that
illness in one part of the country
necessarily will infiltrate other parts
of the country
so i don't know i don't know eddie
california too right
resurgent there too but at least i think
the reaction there will be more rational
so yes if the world is better i'd be
happy to accept your invitation to come
to caltech in 2021 but i just don't know
i just don't know um
all right a few more questions before we
wrap this up
i'm anderson you're the best house thank
you m anderson it gives me more energy
to keep on going
but i'm not like the guy at the
political top here i don't need flattery
but i don't mind it but i don't need it
that's the difference
who doesn't like to hear nice things
about themselves
but it is pathological when you
absolutely need it and can't live
without it and will do anything
lie cheat steal break the law
in order that you can get it you know
what i'm talking about right
you know it's sort of like voldemort
i will not mention his name and by the
way i did
follow your advice i've watched all
harry potter films with my son
except film number two he wouldn't show
me number two for some reason he didn't
like that
i've now seen all the harry potter love
it was great so thank you for
encouraging me to do that but
uh yeah like like voldemort i will not
mention
the name of the person to whom my small
diatribe is referring okay back to
physics
um maria mario
cognac i'm going into high school soon
and i'm hoping to go into a field
revolving around space do you have any
advice for volunteering
classes and so forth and
i would say maria number one the number
one priority is to do your work in
school
study the basics hard study
the basics of physics and chemistry and
biology and
and what other other sciences your high
school might offer
learn the material inside out don't
shirk that chore which is vital
in favor of volunteering and doing
research projects and things of that
sort but if you find
that you can master all the material
that you need to master and you still
have additional time and
energy on your hands by all means
contact professors at a nearby
university contact graduate students in
nearby university let them know that
you're interested to
work on a project with them look i did
this when i was quite young
when i was in junior high school i had
finished
everything that my local public schools
is 44
on 76th street in manhattan i exhausted
everything that they had to offer in
mathematics so a teacher gave me a
letter and i recently found this letter
right i was telling you guys that my mom
passed away so i went back into her
apartment and i've been cleaning out her
things
and one of the letters i found was a
letter
that my seventh grade teacher wrote for
me gave to me
and said go up to columbia university
and knock on doors and the letter
basically said
can you use this kid in some research
project or some class or something
because he's hungry to learn
and i handed this to various people and
i handed it to one graduate student in
mathematics
and he read it and he said yeah i'd be
happy to teach you we didn't have any
money
it wasn't for any financial gain
and he met with me for multiple days
over the course of
weeks during the summer every saturday i
would take the bus
up to la salle street 125th
street in manhattan walk over to
claremont avenue
and this this graduate student neil
bellen said
it was so generous i mean i think back
on it i'm like
it's so astounding every saturday he'd
get up early
to teach this kid for a couple hours
number theory and geometry and
and various other things of that sort
and allowed me
to sort into regions of the mathematical
universe that
in any other
[Music]
context i would have never encountered
and it had a profound impact on me in
fact a statement that he made to me
statement that neil balanced he made to
me is the very first sentence
in in my book until the end of time
and so you should do that maybe your
teacher can write you a letter or maybe
there's a nearby university where you
can knock on people's doors
and if you can find the right person i
was fantastically fortunate
but if you can find the right person it
can be
life transforming so maria i would
encourage you to do your work
but follow the passion that your
questions suggest that you have
and find somebody to nurture your talent
and enthusiasm
okay
let's see uh mr castle dk asked why is
the top quark
so much larger than other quarks and
larger i think you mean by mass and
you're right it is
spectacularly larger much heavier much
more massive
and nobody has an answer we do not know
why the particles the fundamental
particles of nature have the masses that
they do
and they span many orders of magnitude
right i mean the electron you know you
know
roughly one two thousandth the mass of
the proton
and then the top cork you know you know
roughly what is 170 odd times the mass
of a proton
right huge range many factors of 10
but nobody nobody has any explanation
for why those fundamental particles have
the masses that
they do that's one of the goals maybe
unified theory
would be able to do that i don't know
you know
that would be that would be really cool
really
spectacular but no one has been able to
do that yet now look
having said that we do understand
how it is that quarks come together
and yield the mass of a proton using
quantum chromodynamics
and lattice gauge theory researchers
some of them are good friends of mine
have been able to
calculate the mass of these combinations
of particles
we don't know the masses we don't have
an explanation for the masses of the
fundamental constituents
but when we group them together we have
been able to use our understanding of
physics
to predict the mass of the conglomerate
like a proton
so there is insight to the masses of
some
entities but we do not have
insight into the fundamental particles
themselves at least not as yet
so that's uh that's where things stand
on that
carbon heart triple zero i have great
respect for you dr green i hope i can
meet you in person one day thank you
carbon heart
if our paths were to cross someday
remind me of
this message and this conversation and
i'd be uh
more than happy to talk physics and the
universe with you
kenny biddle if the big bang happened in
0.3 seconds
98 of the known universe trillions of
light years in every direction so what
about the speed of light limit
kenny i guess i get what you're after
you're after
how could the universe have grown so big
in such a tiny fraction of a second
if nothing can go faster than the speed
of light and kenny
the the issue there is to really
understand deeply what
the dictum that nothing can go fast in
the speed of light what does it mean
what it really means is that no entity
no object
can pass through space and speed